Doctor Who news Russell T Davis has  revealed that the Christmas specials are  coming back this will be replacing the  New Year's specials that chimney had  opted for tip no feeling that there was  more creative potential in that and he  didn't feel that there was as much left  to do with the Christmas specials but  obviously that resulted in a ratings  drop no matter what you think of those  specials but they're now going to come  back we're not getting one this year we  all should have known that but starting  next year they should be and  additionally he revealed that doctor who  will have no more Gap years because  starting under Moffett and then it also  happened under chimney there would  sometimes be years where we got no new  episodes or at least not a new proper  series and maybe we only got the holiday  special and no other new Doctor Who he's  saying the Gap years are done it's going  to be continuous and you know what both  those things  those make me happy